We already watched this, we watched it, do you want to watch it again?
Oh yeah.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Okay.
How you're scored.
So, as you can see, your pattern is scored based on the number 10.
So, out of 10 is your 1.
As you can see, it's split up into two parts.
We have our accuracy and our presentation on this side.
So, we'll start off with the accuracy first.
So, your accuracy is actually scored from a 4.
So, from the number 4, you're actually marked during your presentation of your pattern.
And then with that one, any mistakes that you make, if it's a minor mistake, you get a minus of 0.1.
If it's a major mistake...
If it's a major mistake, you get a minus of 0.3.
So, I'll just let you guys know about the difference between the two.
So, with a minor mistake, it's a very, very small thing.
So, say we're doing an outer block.
If it's not your shoulder height, maybe it's a little bit lower, or maybe it's a tiny bit higher, that's a minor mistake, so that's a 0.1.
A major mistake would be, you're supposed to do an outer block in the pattern, but you forget and you say you do a reach hand strike instead.
So, that would be a major mistake.
So, with a minor mistake, let's say pattern 1, for example, there's 20 steps, it's not uncommon to have up to maybe 14, 15 mistakes in the 20 steps.
So, the reason for that would be, it needs to be absolutely perfect to not get a deduction of 0.1.
So, it's not uncommon, let's say, there's 20 steps, and you make...
Let's say 15 mistakes.
So, what would that be?
So, we'll leave that there on this side, and we'll come back and we'll just calculate the score at the end.
So, a major mistake, say you're supposed to turn to the left, when you turn to the right, that would be a major mistake.
So, obviously, we do want to try and avoid any of these major mistakes.
So, after we've done our pattern, that's when we move on to the presentation side.
So, the presentation, as you can see, it's from a score of 6.
This 6 is actually split up into three parts.
So, we have 1, 2, 3 here.
So, with this one, for a score of 2 is your power and speed.
Your rhythm is also a score of 2, and your expression of energy is also scored out of 2 as well.
So, we'll start off with the power and speed.
So, with this one, whether it's your blocks, your kicks, your strikes, your punches, anything that you do, it needs to be nice and strong, and it has to be fast as well.
So, it's one thing to have a very strong punch, or a very fast punch, but it has to be both strong and fast to get high in that category.
So, the next part is your rhythm.
So, the rhythm, when you do start your pattern, there is a rhythm to the pattern.
It's not just really fast all the way through.
It's not slow all the way through.
There's a slow, fast, slow, fast kind of aspect to it as well.
So, you do need to kind of work on the rhythm, and that's also scored out of 2.
The last bit is your expression of energy.
So, what is expression of energy?
So, that's basically how loud you shout, so how much intensity you have during your pattern as well.
So, say you're doing your pattern really well.
It's really fast and it's strong.
Your rhythm is really great, but you're not shouting very loud.
Or, you can kind of tell, the judges can kind of tell that you're not really confident.
You're a little bit nervous.
So, that's why we need to kind of do that.
We're going to move on as well.
So, I'll just come around to this side.
So, with this one, for colour belts and black belts, it's actually scored a little bit differently.
So, if you're a colour belt, you'll actually, your average, so where the judges actually mark you from,
it's actually from a 1.1.
So, this is your average.
So, say you did alright, you did average compared to everyone else.
Your score for 1, 2, and 3, it'll start from a 1.1.
So, if you're less than average in the judges' eyes, you might go down to, say for your power and speed,
you might get a 1 or even a 0.9.
If you did really great, you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.3.
So, each individual category, you need to obviously get as high as you can.
If you're a black belt, generally, depending on the competition, you will be scored from a 1.3.
So, 1.3 would be your average that you start from.
So, say your power and speed was above average, you might get scored a 1.4 for now.
Say your rhythm was only about average, it wasn't amazing, it might be just a 1.3.
But let's say you didn't shout very loud.
So, your expression of energy, your average was 1.3, it might drop to, say, let's say a 1.0.
So, that's that.
With this one, we'll come over down to this side.
So, with this one, as I was saying, it's a total of 10.
So, let's see.
For presentation, we had 1.7, 1, 2, 3.
So, you added 3.7.
Let's say you made 15 mistakes.
So, with this one, obviously, don't be too discouraged if you do get pretty high in your mistakes.
With the judges, we have three judges usually at the panel.
And each judge, obviously, is very subjective.
So, from their point of view, you might have made a lot of mistakes or you may have made not a lot of mistakes as well.
So, that's why we have three judges and we average it out as well.
Okay. So, say we did our 15 mistakes, very small mistakes.
So, if they're all minus 0.1, it'd be 1.5.
So, you go 4.0 minus 1.5, which equals 2.5.
So, this would be your accuracy score.
So, with our presentation like before, we're saying we got a 3.7.
So, we add these numbers after the judges are finished scoring.
So, you would get, for this pattern, a 6.2, which is actually very good.
So, I'll just talk a little bit more now about this number here.
So, if you're a color belt, if you're a yellow or above and you do your patterns, it's not uncommon.
Generally, for a color belt, the average is about a 4 to 5.
So, if you get a number between 4 and 5 out of 10 for your pattern, that's actually generally considered pretty good.
So, anything above that, you can consider yourself pretty good.
If you're a black belt, the average would say, because we're talking here about the high presentation as an average,
anything from 5 to 6.
It's actually considered pretty good.
And anything over a 7 is actually considered almost world-class.
So, if you get a 7 for any of your patterns, you generally need to pat yourself on the back.
You did an amazing job.
So, we just went through our 4.2 scoring.
So, just remember, accuracy is a 4.0 presentation.
So, do I just like start the video now?
Yeah.
So, just watch and then I score after?
Yes.
You're going to be scoring right away.
Okay.
So...
We're going to be...
But this is the minor errors.
Real time.
Okay.
Major errors.
And then after the performance, you read your power and speed, coordination of rhythm, and your expression of energy.
Okay.
And then we submit.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's start.
That'd be it.
Cool.
Thanks.
Okay.
So, let's go over 8.
You're starting.
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright.
Thank you.